السعوديه تحتفي بمحمد منير غموض حول منع
عرض فيلم سبايدر مان الجديد في الخليج هل
تحاشى محمد رمضان المنافسه مع تامر حسني
اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
بعد النجاح الكبير الذي حققه عرض فيلم
سبايدر مان الجديد
في امريكا الشماليه سادت حاله من الغموض
حول سبب عدم ادراج الفيلم على قوائم
العروض المنتظره في صالات السينما بدول
الخليج والذي كان مقررا في الثاني
والعشرين من حزيران يونيو الجاري الحساب
الرسمي للسينما السعودي على تويتر علق على
ذلك بالقول من حرصنا على سلامه المحتوى
المعروض في صالات السينما ومسؤولياتنا
تجاه المشاهدين نود التنويه باننا لن نقوم
باجازه اي فيلم يتعارض مع ضوابط المحتوى
المعمول بها في نظام الاعلام المرئي
والمسموع ولائحته التنفيذيه ما لم تلتزم
شركات الانتاج بتنفيذ التعديلات المطلوبه
وشارك الحساب بوستر فيلم سبايدر مان
الجديد مع عباره دائما خذوا الاخبار من
مصادرها الرسميه الهيئه لم تستقبل حتى
الان طلب فسخ وتصنيف فيلم
في حين اكتفى مجلس الامارات للاعلام
بالتنويه للموضوع عبر حسابه الرسمي على
تويتر في تغريده جاء فيها يعمل مجلس
الامارات للاعلام على متابعه وتقييم
المحتوى الاعلامي المتداول المحليا ويؤكد
المجلس بانه لن يسمح بتداول او نشر محتوى
مخالف لقيم ومبادئ دوله الامارات ومعايير
المحتوى الاعلامي المعمول بها في الدوله
وذلك دون الاشاره لهذا الفيلم بوضوح ورجح
التقارير الاعلاميه ان السبب وراء المنع
هو ظهور عباره احمو الاطفال المتحولين
جنسيا في خلفيه احد المشاهد وواجه فيلم
سلسله افلام توي ستوري مصيرا مماثلا العام
الماضي وسبقه حظر فيلم الابديون في دول
الخليج ودول عربيه واسلاميه اخرى في العام
2021 لاسباب مماثله
سينمائيا ايضا ومع اقتراب موعد عرض فيلم
بيت الروبي من بطوله كريم عبد العزيز
وكريم محمود عبد العزيز اتضحت خارطه موسم
افلام عيد الاضحى في مصر وتضم فيلم تاج من
بطوله تامر حسني ودين الشربيني ومستر اكس
من بطوله احمد فهمي وهنا الزاهد والبعبع
من بطوله امير كراره وياسمين صبري وذلك
بعد اعلان العدل جروب الاسبوع الماضي عن
تاجيل عرض فيلم الزيرو من بطوله محمد
رمضان ونيللي كريم نظرا لعدم الانتهاء من
تصوير الفيلم في حين افادت تقارير اعلاميه
بان سبب الحقيقي وراء التاجيل قد يكون عدم
رغبه محمد رمضان بالمنافسه مع كريم عبد
العزيز وتامر حسني في موسم واحد ومع عوده
رمضان لاستئناف تصوير فيلم عزيرو اعلن
رسميا عن انتاج جزء ثاني من مسلسل جعفر
العمده تحت اداره المخرج محمد سامي لموسم
رمضان 2024 وذلك بعد النجاح الكبير الذي
حققه الجزء الاول
انا كنت بره ولا مهاجر اعمل لي جايلك من
باكر واخيرا احتفت هيئه الترفيع السعوديه
الاسبوع الماضي بمسيره الفنان المصري محمد
منير في ليله مشواري التي اقيمت ضمن
فعاليات تقويم جده وشارك فيها فرقه
موسيقيه ضخمه بقياده المايسترو هاني فرحات
انضم اليها عازفون عالميون قدموا عرضا
موسيقيا سيبقى في ذاكره طويلا بمشاركه
الكينج وعلى ايقاع مختارات من اشهر اغاني
وشهد الحفل لحظات مؤثره غنى فيها المطرب
احمد سعد تكريما لمنير وكذلك فرقه كايروكي
الشهيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]